et depuis 3h ce matin à l'ensemble des
salariés du site xp au logistique sont
en grève à trappes du manifeste pour une
nouvelle organisation de la logistique
avec un groupe de grande distribution
annoncée par la direction de la semaine
dernière pour l'occasion un
intersyndicale a été créée hier
il regroupe force ouvrière la cgt la
cftc la cgc et la hesse ap cette
nouvelle organisation représenterait une
perte de 50 % du volume traité par xo
logistique
les syndicats demandent donc l'arrêt
immédiat du projet selon lé délégué
syndical de la cgt environ 130 postes
pourraient être supprimés
écoutez ces précisions recueillies au
micro de camille lambert fort chez moi
au moins de volumes moins d'effectifs
derrière ces cinq rats font notre faim
aujourd'hui si ces suppressions de
postes et là on est là aujourd'hui pour
montrer à la direction qu'on est
déterminé qu on va tout faire pour
garder pour sauvegarder l'emploi de nos
collègues s'appauvrissent mais ça peut
dire est comme ça peut être des semaines
que si aujourd'hui on a des réponses
satisfaisantes on reprendra le travail
de mal mais pour l'instant on n'a
toujours pas de réponse même le
déterminer aller jusqu'au bout et nous
avons bien sûr compte est t x p ô
logistique dans un communiqué un porte
parole affirme que je cite ledit client
un grand groupe de distribution n'y a
fait part de sa volonté de faire évoluer
l'organisation logistique de son
activité multi formats en ile-de-france
cette évolution inscrit la collaboration
de longue date entre ce client et xp
logistique dans la durée les niveaux
d'activité qui sont confiées avec ce que
logistiques seront maintenus à des
niveaux proches de ceux actuellement
traités par ses équipes le groupe
poursuit actuellement ses échanges avec
son client pour travailler ensemble la
définition de la future organisation de
l'activité
il a invité ses collaborateurs en grève
à reprendre le dialogue